yeah welcome to this video bit but lady
I had the sound turn off and I need to
you need to switch it on again playing a
five minute game and forgot the Evans
gambit
whoops of course I am me about play
Bishop d7 normally this was a bad mouth
slip I don't know not the most lip and I
was just not really concentrated hmm
don't know yeah just a check-in probably
so um I hope this is still um still a
playable position for me to take it
yeah maybe 97 right have six runs into
e5 yeah I thought d5
maybe it's it's not possible maybe I can
go I mean I D 5 I need to play anyway
and what what now
fatigue take on d5 he might play my play
night at 7 or Queen f3 for that matter
but take d4 that's d6 IAM hmm okay
Knight a5 this also looking a bit
uncomfortable but yeah it's probably not
bad
and I'm not sure if it's the best
solution but it should be you should be
playable
Queen a4 c6 you can take maybe on c6
yeah this is this is a bit annoying
you can take on c6 yeah
yeah probably I need to I need to castle
then I take on c4 he has some takes on
b7 birth chick and I don't want to play
yeah don't want to face that maybe this
is still alright I mean I I intend to
take his bishop I can take on c6 yeah or
this one
but this really speeds up my development
nicely I also have this possibility of a
Discoverer to check on the knight on d5
well at the moment I'm torn down the
some wasn't really intended
Jeff role you can play something like
Bishop d3 attacking age 700 treating
this piece he lets me
he actually allows the capture this is
surprising this very bad night on a5 to
capture the strong Bishop okay maybe I'm
only yeah maybe I'm thinking about this
in two general terms this is possible
and it's just a concrete concrete man I
met him go here attacking d4 I can go
into Knight f3 simply yeah okay it's
probably it's probably a pawn down with
not too great compensation he just needs
to go Knight f3
alright yeah maybe I had some battles
don't see it at the moment but possibly
it's not it's not completely terrible I
mean you have a very good Bishop but
it's not not really am for full
compensation mmm YUM 25 probably that's
the bishop is very strong on d5 I don't
mind the Queen exchange the bishop
attacks the a pawn and I can pressurize
the forum but some it's okay probably
not a big problem
now if he takes I'm I can enter won't be
to f6 takes away the e5 + g5 square I'm
now actually threatening to take on B
one to get the pawn back so he needs to
to do something ok
yeah well the bishop is still great on
d5 and my knight has got potential
he also now has an unprotected knight on
f3 so oh he's getting into the the pin
directly yeah maybe
threatening rook a - I'm not even sure
that I'm that I'm Bruce
really how does he protected
yeah this is just a very good piece on
d5 bishops bishops are stronger than
Knights in most cases and this is one of
those cases okay just just TM and what
is this g5 figure goes to e3 it's not a
mate
unfortunately so Luke takes yeah Brooke
takes probably threatened takes a three
and 9c3
with the win and also 95 with when so
I'm very difficult so Knight g5 is this
enough
g5 has got King III and this is not not
enough this this was for me was this
enough hmm 1592 it really looks like
there should be a direct winner
don't see it though he cannot really
move much King III maybe okay I'm taking
too much time him
so it's probably not not the best I
spent too much time for this
yeah I should have come for this quick
up it is this this this I take night
against Bishop
he's getting this pawn hmm but I can I
can trip the night and almost it almost
yeah it will end in a draw me I should
have one night you never really at the
end when I didn't find a win in this in
this position where where he was pinned
there is certainly a direct win but I
didn't see it in this position here you
know
rook F 1 and -6
yes it's really not difficult but okay
it splits chess is this winning as well
no not so clear it is very very good for
black but the problem with this move is
yeah what this does not do it cannot go
here this wentz very easily and this I
have yeah I have g5 LG v strong yeah
well you can find it I should find it
really with one minute on the clock it's
not there not too difficult I didn't I
didn't do it and this is of course very
good but it's not not an easy win
I could just take a three-hour plank
badly just a three
well I instantly went for this because
it is clearly better but probably just a
draw there there too
not not enough pawns on the board this
is the problem he P just who will get
get assistances an instant wrong but of
course they are very bad play this this
is just winning because he's in the spin
and I just take on a three next move
nothing you can do about that
yeah well those games happen in the
first game of a session thanks for
watching